il aurait couché a fait vite 6 mètres
par endroits
alors on est et où déjà chaque soir au
moment de l'endormir
le père de sofia devient le prince d'un
monde merveilleux inventé pour elle
et chaque soir j'avais eu peut-être le
prince sa princesse
jusqu'au jour où commence a pas
d'histoire
papa gens nous ont amenés fortes
seulement trois mots qui compte c'est la
fin mon pote voile au lac ce monsieur
pouvait pas rentrer le prince va arriver
je suis le prince hylas 1
les princes
segosa
mon père a toujours été très présent
mais un certain âge j'aimais bien qu'ils
me laissent un petit peu d'air
les oublis et c'est là où on en voit les
personnages quand ils sont plus aucune
histoire
et disparaît sans fondement welcome to
the oubliette expliquer ça c'est tout
moi tu viens pas me dérange pas c'est
ton père
ses connaissances lui que vous êtes un
super papa il faut bien la laisser
grandir
bloqués ici et d'autre et sans issue
pas bien
et toutes les histoires leurs pensées
leurs oublis
après c'est pendant qu'ils font chier